good afternoon everyone my name is dr
miller and the scp we're going to be
looking at today is scp-4255
object class
ketter
special containment procedures
due to the widespread knowledge of the
base anomalous properties of scp-4255
it has been given the secondary
classification of a cracked veil
uncontained anomaly in order to suppress
further information of scp-4254
procedure yule2 has been created
procedure yule2 occurs as follows
annually on 12pm coordinated universal
time november 22nd memetic agents are to
be implemented into all forms of media
including television programs new works
of literature foundation front accounts
on social media websites and various
forms of performing and visual arts
these memetic agents are designed to
implant false memories into parents or
guardians of any children who celebrate
the holiday christmas these memories
include the purchasing of gifts that
will be given to their children by
scp-4255 on december 25th and the
placing of said gifts on that night by
scp-4255
any individuals which have been
unaffected by the memetic treatment
described above are to be located and
manually treated
starting on 8 pm coordinated universal
time december 24th two unarmed military
aircrafts are to locate track and follow
all temporal versions of scp-4255
and make note of any noticeable changes
in behavior from scp-4255
lethal force is not permitted when
interacting with scp-4255
when all versions of
scp-4255 have vanished all foundation
interference is to cease
after 12 am coordinated universal time
december 25th social media is to be
tracked for any images of or accounts
with scp-4255
and images or conspiracy theories
centered around procedure yule2 any
offending pieces of information are to
be labeled as hoax or erased with the
publishers being located and treated to
class a amnestics in extreme cases all
viewers of information described above
are to be treated with class a amnestics
with all social media being cleansed of
any information on
scp-4255 or procedure yule2 that these
cases could spawn
efforts to partake in a secondary
interview with scp-4255
are to be attempted as scp-4255
seems to possess valuable information on
controllable temporal anomalies and on
the historical future of the human race
description
scp-4255
is a humanoid male with an aged
appearance approximately 1.4 meters in
height and 150 kilograms in weight
scp-4255 appears to be in his 60s or 70s
however reports of
scp-4255 manifestations have dated back
to 400 a.d
scp-4255 possesses a similar appearance
to the traditional attire of the
character santa claus no current
connection between scp-4255
and the bishop saint nicholas have been
made
along with the red and gold ornate
sleigh that his character is known to be
present in designated scp-4255
1.
scp-4255-1 is capable of flight via
unknown means and is able to travel at
speeds of approximately 100 kilometers
per hour with
scp-4255 remaining inside scp-4255-1
during flight even when scientifically
impossible
scp-4255-1 is drawn by eight servant
animals resembling rangifer tarantus
also known by the names caribou or
reindeer although infrared scans show
that these do not possess any heat
signatures and it is currently unknown
if these are living organisms
scp-4255 manifestations periodically
occur at 8 pm coordinated universal time
december 24th each year during which
scp-4255 will appear somewhere
approximately 1 kilometers in the air
above the earth's surface in scp-4255-1
scp-4255 and or scp-4255-1
appear to possess the ability to
generate small-scale temporal anomalies
during its appearances as many as 294
versions of scp-4255
are present on across the globe at once
with many versions processing visual
differences that have not yet occurred
to scp-4255
from a linear standpoint
scp-4255 manifestations always follow a
similar pattern of events after its
initial appearance
scp-4255 will land on the roof or near a
household of individuals that celebrate
the holiday christmas regardless of
religious background and will use its
temporal abilities to enter the
household
scp-4255 will then produce a multitude
of wrapped gifts and toys with number of
gifts given varying from child to child
it is also of note that
scp-4255 has a significant understanding
of the likes and dislikes of each child
on earth with presents given having an
82.56
accuracy rate compared to what the
children would like to have received for
a gift at that time
all recorded gifts have been
non-anomalous with scp-42
actively avoiding the giving of gifts a
child wants if it could be classified as
anomalous
scp-4255 will repeat this pattern until
all children who celebrate christmas on
the planet have received at least one
gift from it attempts to approach
scp-4255
or
scp-4255-1 in an effort to capture
either anomaly on the ground or in the
sky have resulted in failure with
scp-4200
using its temporal abilities to evade
capture
addendum
4255 1.
before an
scp-4255 manifestation on the year 2018
several houses of foundation personnel
were equipped with audio transmission
devices which was then used to make an
official direct contact with scp-4255
for the first time on record
log 4255
1 interviewed scp-4255
interviewer researcher mayor
begin log
hello
can you hear me
who is this this is researcher charles
mayer
i come from an organization with the szp
foundation they told me i'd run into you
guys today
aren't you the people always trailing in
those jets
those things are out up close you know
um the scp foundation yes
who do you mean by they
uh
well
it's probably gonna mess up time and
cause some butterfly effect [ __ ] but
they told me to tell you guys this for
some reason
well
they're called the us department of
chronology
pretty stupid name if you ask me
chronology sounds like the most sci-fi
thing ever
what year is it right now
i want to make sure i don't say anything
too major
2018
oh god
well they said there's some government
branch that keeps check over time travel
and stuff and
well they sort of forced me to do this
i'd like to go find stuff from the past
and well
take it
i had one of hitler's paintings before
a block from those pyramids that were in
africa you know stuff like that i'm
afraid i don't quite follow
what does this have to do with you being
well
being i'm getting to that just give me a
sec
so one day some government cronies came
and took me away
thought i was being careful i did but i
guess not careful enough
probably have some way to detect time
travel
anyway
they told me i had to do this
looked like i got off easy but this got
boring after a while
been doing this for like
two two and a half years
one christmas every day
i see so
do you have a real name then
stan clean
i
haven't been born yet
that's always a weird thing to say
you probably know me as santa claus or
something like that
you tell a kid your name at the 5th
century and the half deaf little [ __ ]
tells everyone your name is santa claus
i hope some crazy government shoots me
out of the sky so i can get this hell
over with
if you're a
time traveler
then
when are you from
2099
huh
well then how do you have such a good
understanding of each child's wants for
the holiday is is this some sort of
future technology
not sure i can tell you that i've caused
enough paradoxes with this one interview
already
wait a second
are you guys gonna put this in a
document or something yes this will be
logged in [ __ ]
that's how they knew they read this damn
log excuse me i ain't saying anything
else
uses a temporal anomaly to vacate the
area in scp-4255-1
and log
closing statement
scp-4255
refused all efforts to cooperate with
questioning after the events of this
interview and instead yelled obscenities
at interviewers when attempts to
question were made no records of a stan
klein matching
scp-4255's description have been found
addendum 4255
2.
on september 4th 2097 the foundation
department of chronology was formed
after the discovery of replicatable
controllable travel non-linearly through
time was discovered after parallels
between
scp-4255s described host organization
and the newly formed department were
made stan klein a man matching the
physical description of scp-4220
was tracked and placed into foundation
custody it was later found that klein
had access to a temporal anomaly
allowing him to travel through time
non-linearly
to avoid a possible ck-class reality
configuration scenario or a pt-class
paradoxical time breakdown scenario the
foundation is to give claim the full
capabilities to perform the actions of
scp-4255
along with the recorded appearance of
scp-4255
a large sleigh built to the
specifications of scp-4255-1
was created using several anomalies
making it capable of controllable flight
along with the sleigh and clane being
equipped with devices designed to create
small scale temporal anomalies eight
heat-resistant models resembling the now
extinct rangifer tyrandus were attached
to the front of the sleigh in a manner
that suggests that they are pulling the
craft behind them
gifts given are to be produced by the
beta temporal knowledge artificial
intelligence unit commonly abbreviated
as btk ai an ai created by the
foundation that uses time anomalies to
know all information across linear time
frames while the btkai unit currently
only knows information up to an
undisclosed year in the 21st century
this year is expected to change at a
rate that will be constant enough for
clain to fulfill his duties all other
information to the btk ai unit is
classified it is currently unknown when
claim will finish his duties as
scp-4255 will finish his role as
scp-4255
on christmas day on an undisclosed year
within the 22nd century
this concludes today's lecture thank you
for listening if indeed you still are
happy holidays or whatever you celebrate
and you're all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
ian j alsop
zargaran
professor puffer
the morrigan
retalias
karim el ashmuy
savanity
kristoff kozak slesak
hms lily
the almighty fish
gav the clumsy containment specialist
spooky aqua
pure osmium
scio dio damnares
brian sanchez
matthew gilmore
drew peacock
eric corbeage
longinus
james saba
and
njvojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the vogen
thank you
you